feel uh you know obviously
as somebody who
was incarcerated for Mariko and the RICO
stuff that's happening in hip-hop
obviously in Atlanta
um
and it feels like that the snitching
thing is a lot more prevalent than it's
ever been because paperwork is I guess
easy easier to get to I don't know but
like what are your thoughts on just like
how artists should move nowadays
not necessarily if they're officially
wrapped up in anything but it it feels
like the wrong the right people are
watching and I guess they're the wrong
people watching so it's like
for you like if you could give advice to
anybody
going through a RICO like you know what
would what for you like
what would be some advice you would give
some of these artists and and how should
people move man because I feel like
people move so flagrantly they put so
much [__] on the internet
but that is that's a serious charge bro
yeah especially if it's a federal one
it is a federal charge and it's a state
charge but it's a serious [__] charge
you know what I'm saying especially
especially if you've been a prison of in
the in and out the system
you know what I'm saying right it's a
serious [__] charge it's hella
stressful
I've been through it and I went through
that [__] for almost two and a half
years before I went to jail me and all
my co-defendants
um
we just live in like a time where like
everything is so serious like
nobody don't want to hear lies or like
[__]
so these guys is like willing to throw
it all on the line for like some extreme
credibility
situation like it works until you yeah
yeah you might go platinum but then you
might go sit down then you might you
might lose it all and it's risky you
know what I'm saying and then and and
the question is all right is it worth it
I think the internet too desensitizes
every like we're all desensitized to
like real consequences because so many
people could just do [__] on the
internet and it doesn't affect them they
don't think it affects them and I think
everybody yeah
these charges man like
like one of my like two of my Cody
finishers was fighting definitely you
feel me one of my co-defendants got 30
to 60 years plus 15 Jesus two of my
co-defense got nine years one of them
got eight
two of us got two years like you know
what I'm saying
none of us uh
cooperated or did nothing like that we
all went to court together right
I don't speak on nobody else cases uh
you know what I'm saying
I think that's kind of like the if if
they bring those charges against you
they're kind of hoping that it's like a
numbers game like if we get 20 of these
guys like me all we need is a wonderful
what it is is that
with us
it was like these guys animals get these
guys off the street
I wasn't even in a I wouldn't none of
them I just get every like no paper
but they like [__] they all get them all
you don't have to be doing nothing but
if you over there and if you sing with
these guys and if you've known for
posting these guys on your page or
friends or not you in the loop
you feel what I'm saying you in the loop
now no matter what you did because they
can make him say you did something for
him to cut this time lose your game off
the hook he'll say you did something
right A lot of these people be on case
with people they don't even know you
feel what I'm saying I'd have been like
that with people like 60 people in that
case they don't know half of them that's
crazy that's that's that's what's crazy
it's like I don't know what the [__]
that is I'm serious bro you know what
I'm saying so
in order to dodge these situations you
gotta start by having fun with music
like everybody want to kill each other
like
[__] all that you know what I'm saying
like [__] all that like
I like flash it like you know
it's so fun flying somewhere and going
shopping and living in the best hotels
and swimming and
pools on top of La at the Waldorf of
radios and all you know what I'm saying
like a lot of these young [__] will
never see that right because they they
living so serious you gotta have some
fun that's the only way to die is to
start back having fun and also the Dodge
like like that gives you some peace just
have fun like come on man like I feel
like everybody's trying to prove
something a lot of [__] can't be taken
back in the street man I get it like you
know what I'm saying but it's it used to
be a time and a place for [__] like the
internet ain't for
it's not for that like they bring them
they bring that [__] there and it's
[__] the game up mm-hmm it's really
[__] the game up and we all did it we
all made mistakes like nobody perfect
you know of course of course everybody
got caught up in the moment and did some
internet [__] you know what I'm saying
but us as a whole
and um we [__] the game up bringing
the street [__] to the internet right
for you making it so easy for them and
then I could cut you off but
when these [__] get these Ricoh charge
a lot of them never had money
you feel what I'm saying
a lot of these [__] don't got nothing
when they go to jail but
they ride around these guns and these
cars and do this I shouldn't they go to
jail and then they they don't got
nothing you know what I'm saying yeah
no I see it all the time man even like
people who aren't artists just like
normal people get some money yeah so
when you do get these charges you don't
got to be caught along tomorrow man
[__] fake [__] I ain't never calling
they call home for [__] when I was in
jail I had my money put up I had my [__]
put in places and and I had two
trustworthy people who I knew was gonna
move for me right I ain't had to call
home have nobody for the [__] so
whatever I was already doing I could
stand it I could get in trouble I can
get myself out of it if I want my lawyer
money and
I ain't never had the car also
these [__] get in trouble and they
don't got no money it's bad for sure
um
suspensive in jail bro